und da ich hab da mal ne frage der neue
film mit tom gerhardt die superbullen
ist mit 200.000 besuchern in den ersten
vier tagen der beste neustart 2011 in
dem klamauk macht tom gerhardt als tommy
wieder köln kalk und den rest der welt
unsicher
praktisch da steht
in der online talkshow clixoom de
erzählte tom gerhardt nicht nur viel
privates sondern kam auch zu
unverhofften ehren der kalker
bezirksbürgermeister markus thiele
überfiel die gesprächsrunde und hatte
eine überraschung der ball sehr geehrter
herr gerhard hier mit verlaub ich ihnen
herrn tom gerhardt geboren am 12
dezember
1957 in kraft meines von den kickerinnen
und karten verliehenen amtes im
vollbesitz seiner geistigen kräfte die
ehrenbürgerschaft der ehemaligen freien
reichsstadt kaut rheinland zum ersten
mal wird diese hohe auszeichnung
verliehen der bezirksbürgermeister hat
sich mit der spaßaktion viel mühe
gegeben und eine ausgeklügelte laudatio
verfasst sollte diese pflicht nicht
eingehalten werden können droht im
schlimmsten falle
lebenslanges fahrverbot
ich spüre ehrenburg